l'aco vide à port au prince la deuxième
vague a bien atteint haïti on voit de
temps en temps des gens masqués mais
visiblement ce n'est pas une grande
préoccupation d'autant plus que le pays
est encore sous le choc de l'assassinât
du président georges moise et de la
vague de violence des gangs armés qui
l'a précédé fait en haïti comme très
préoccupante mais ce n'est pas à cause
de la qu'ovide là la situation
aujourd'hui est ce que je peux dire
n'était pas catastrophique on n'a pas
des chiffres de mortalité à ce jour
absolument alarmant cela étant dit les
conditions sont réunionnais pourrait
effectivement l'épidémie explose de
l'épidémie explose peut-être pas à cas
on s'est trompé pour la première vague
il y un peu plus d'un an prévoyait 300
mille cas et douze mille morts les
derniers chiffres officiels cent de
moins de vingt mille cas est un peu plus
de 500 morts au total même s'ils étaient
deux ou trois fois supérieur en réalité
on est loin de l'hécatombe annoncé
d'abord morceau spiritualiste moi
quoique bon dié épargnées non
deuxièmement dont on croit dans la
science en partie originale du fleur
réparateur de téléphones crois qu'il a
eu la qu'ovide mais il n'est pas sûr car
il ne s'est pas fait tester mais quand
même nous et salim des capacités pour
résister à maladie ça au magazine q
miniter colis collective la docteure
marie marcel deschamps confirme
l'intuition d'original donc je peux dire
qu'on est en pleine deuxième bague mais
on ne se sent pas aussi fort que la
première vague donc les anticorps
probablement ont joué un rôle est
probablement bien ce qu'on appelle le
real inutile quelque part on ne sait pas
en plus des vaccins qui vont animer donc
ça va s'associer à l'infection donc
l'ati corps l'immunité passé vous avec
une unité produite pas le vaccin
les centres gestion et la docteure des
chansons à l'avant garde de toutes les
maladies infectieuses
effectivement la première vague a frappé
fort mais elle a réservé des surprises
l'infection est rentré fort heureusement
en force
en 2020 la communauté la population
étant jeune il n'y a pas eu un taux de
mortalité aussi levé qu'on a vu en
europe ou en amérique du nord et la
prévalence des anticorps que nous avons
fait cette étude ce qu'on appelle il
jugé elle était dans l'ordre de 7 1 %
dans le groupe on avait déjà des pistes
et près de 7000 personnes qui prouve que
effectivement les gens ont été infectés
cependant cependant il faut pas encore
crier victoire quand il ya aussi la
présence des variantes grâce à la
jeunesse de la population la moitié a
moins de 25 ans les anticorps sont là et
les vaccins arrivent une toute première
cargaison de doses de moderna a été
donnée par les états unis dans le cadre
du programme kovacs elles seront
destinées au personnel de la santé et
aux personnes les plus âgées
cinq cent mille doses ce n'est pas assez
bien sûr pour 11 millions d'habitants
mais la population est elle prête pour
les vaccins
levac si vous voulez je pense que si
c'est la preuve un peu populaire donc
c'est sûr que vacciner sera un défi pour
les centres gestio mais ils ont vu pire
l'épidémie de vih le sida qui a ravagé
haïti dans les années 80 cette ong non
lucratif créée par des haïtiens pour les
haïtiens il ya 40 ans a vaincu le sida
en voici la courbe
le défi était de maintenir les patients
sous traitement par anti viraux
progressivement gestio adopter une
approche globale du sida et des
infections pathologique associée on est
passé à la santé reproductive des femmes
au contrôle des naissances pour éviter
que des bébés naissent avec le sida le
séisme de 2010 a conduit à élargir son
rôle social au delà de la santé et de la
salubrité
dans ses ateliers on enseigne la couture
la production d'objets d'artisanat de
meubles également dans le but de créer
de donner des emplois
et puis il y à l'école primaire pour les
enfants des quartiers défavorisés qui
encercle le centre ils sont en vacances
en ce moment les centres sont un succès
indéniable avec une vision commune du
public et du privé et la transparence
dans l' usage des fonds de l'aide
internationale
c'est le modèle salomonais à la source
il aurait moyen de faire fonctionner le
pays la même façon oui bien sûr il
suffit d'avoir la volonté de vouloir à
le faire de vouloir le faire de se
sacrifier quelque part un certain moment
l'oubli de soi et penser à la mission
voilà mais c'est un modèle est un modèle
qui est applicable et réplicable
pourquoi pas on pourrait le faire pour
le reboisement
on peut le faire pour l'éducation c'est
se mettre ensemble se donner des
objectifs annuels et des objectifs de 5
ans ou de 10 ans et allons suivre la
tendance
ce qu'il faut corriger allons le
corriger ensemble c'est tout simplement
d'esprit d'équipé
voilà un message à transmettre aux
politiciens